we've come up with a scheme which is to
have the expansion on the western end of
the airfield taking up to 130 million
passengers it's not easy to build in the
western end of the airfield obviously
you got the M 25 M 4 and 3 and 40 and so
on as well as sticking to within the
Davis Commission report and having the
South Westerley sorry northwesterly
runway which is the three and a half
thousand meter runway so it was all that
hard work over the past couple of years
would you still have to divert any of
the motorways in the way that the he's
run no no we're sticking to exactly what
was approved what was issued by the
government DFT and the Davis Commission
report there'll be three and a half
thousand meter run me over the m25 but
where we've actually made a big
difference is having the expansion on
the western end of the airfield there's
also about 20% less land take right and
with all those savings and by working
with the partners with the airline's
having the input what would you like
they're the expert they're the ones
actually fly the planes and bring the
passengers in not of Heathrow so working
with them we've got to a plan that
really is far efficient is less than
half of the Heathrow cost so John
Holland Kay the chief executive of heat
row he said your plans are like the
Emperor's New Clothes the more we look
at them there's less to see yeah well I
don't mind being called an emperor but
at the end of the day I think you know
we're very happy
I'm always sent from day one we're very
happy to work with anyone and everyone
I think free for once in life we've
actually got the government and the
Secretary of State and the CA everyone
wants to make it different by getting
this underway as quickly as possible so
we're here to make this success not only
for the airlines not only for Heathrow
but for UK plc and we will do everything
in our power to work with everyone
including Heathrow Airport so it's
really just to say we're here what we do
want to do is make a difference because
it's such a huge project and I think and
there is no harm in having healthy
competition
the latest spanner in the works for the
Heathrow plans is are all these
environmental consider is how do you
shape up on those measures well I think
our plans without all
world-class lead in world leading
advisors and consultants we are if
anything was slightly better we no worse
off than what was there with the
Heathrow plan so I think it's always
just trying to make sure that we can
deliver a world-class expansion at
Heathrow Airport because when I came to
this country in back in the 1970s
Heathrow was top of the world we were
the busiest international airport in the
world and over the years unfortunately
we've fallen behind and whether it's due
by whether you look at Schiphol whether
you look at Madrid when they want to
build runways and when they want to
expand it's not really just about
Heathrow or in the southeast it's
actually the benefit it brings to not
just leisure also the businesses and the
connection to the rest of the world
what's in it for your group should you
succeed here well I think what's in it
for us of course you know it's got to be
right for business and everything else
but I think where we've been success as
a group you know back in the 1990s when
I came up with the idea of the crew
hotel the first of a crew hotel I never
knew nothing about hotels and people
laughed and said this guy you know he
was next way to himself and we'll see
what does he know about hotels and I
said I'm not gonna build them I'm not
gonna run them but what I am gonna do is
bring the best team the best people on
board and my dream was always can we
build a four-star hotel with five-star
service at 3 and a half star prices and
that's exactly the same principle here
one of the other points that John
Holland Kay has raised is why didn't you
put all this to the airport's Commission
when Howard Davis was consulting I I
think what we did not want to do was at
that time there was no firm decision is
the expansion gonna happen a Heathrow or
Gatwick or Stansted whatever part of the
country and I thought it would not be
wise for us to come in and try to muddy
the water let the Davies Commission
report how Davis and his team come up
with the decision first once they come
up with a decision that's the right time
to actually sit there and talk to the
authorities so we've had great support
from the DFT from the government from
the CAA and the airlines and I think
it's a positive thing for everyone
true
to deliver this project as quickly as we
can